all right we're here on overtime
questions from the internet dan Rather
how has the use of social media changed
what and how you report almost in every
way you can think of really the the
Internet and social media have changed
the whole media landscape dramatically
not always for the better and stay tuned
because you ain't seen nothing yet but
you're not one of those shows like I see
all the time on cable where they go I
want to hear what you have to say and
they read some people's stupid tweets no
thank you
and please don't cuz if I ever see you
do that really a jump right out the
window if you ever see me do that have
been committed immediately I okay is
amazing
yeah it's all about what celebrities
hanging out with pool parties and if you
believe that you believe the Pope is
Baptist know broadly do you think
professional athletes today have as good
a chance of entering national politics
as you did why not yeah I don't see any
you know yeah I mean it depends on who
they are I mean so where they run at a
world pieces of what they've met her or
as I call him Metta World War yeah I
mean Jeremy Lin of the Knicks playing
Europe why are you kids but he went to
an Ivy League school didn't he did he
went to Harvard he went to Harvard you
went to Prince works hard he
improvements not all he needs is a team
that moves without the ball I mean could
you please mentor Carmelo Anthony a
little because you I've had difficult
jobs in my life
[Applause]
okay Joel Stein what why pursue
manliness when passive aggression has
brought you so much success that's an
excellent question only got me so far
though especially even with my wife
there's a limit to passive
aggressiveness relationship okay I'll
let you I'll let you get away with that
that dodge Michele why do you think
austerity measures are being rejected
across Europe as evidenced in some
recent elections and how will that
translate to the election here in the US
that's a wonky one so people really hate
it when their taxes go up and their
salaries go down so they want to reject
it but when you run out of money those
are the kind of things that happen when
was the second half what it's the impact
here in the United States translate to
the election this year well I think that
we can look at Europe and say if if we
don't curtail our spending in some way
we have more time than they do they run
out of time but we have time what do you
should look at that what do you think is
gonna happen at this g8 I mean I've
heard talk that they are going to
propose Greece getting off the Euro I
find that very hard to believe I think
at this stage we would still get some
kind of I think we're more likely to get
concessions from Angela Merkel about
being more lenient towards southern
Europe it seems like Germany's at the
end of their patience and we know what
happens then but you know you brought up
this financial this in the show the
whole issue of the financial you're a
lot of people in Europe think wow we got
the Euro to prevent war but it really
feels like Germany is just taking over
all over again
what they say behind closed doors but it
you kind of can't blame the Germans they
I mean look let's not kid ourselves
we've all traveled through Europe people
are very different they may use the same
currency but they're not the same people
the Germans just do work harder it's
just in their blood funny you're in
Greece I mean we are different in this
country you turned the creativity and
the innovation of this country you spark
that you nourished that and you can turn
the economy around all of these
questions are deep in that but we have
to understand that we are somewhat
different we're in danger of the same
thing happening
happen in Greece and in Europe but if we
emphasize particularly education at
every level stop squeezing the
middle-class and develop out of the
middle-class people who innovate new
products Facebook is a recent example of
it you may not like the example but we
we have a tremendous creativity and
innovation in this country and if we can
just spark that if we can nourish it a
little bit we're gonna be ok Facebook
Google and Apple worth eight hundred
billion dollars so we're not quite done
yet I agree there's something really
crucial the difference between the US
and Europe remember the legal structure
is so different in Europe everything is
prohibited until it's allowed so you
have to wait for permission from many
many bureaucrats like anything point
here in the United States everything is
allowed until it's no longer permitted
you've never renovated your home I mean
I can't cut down trees on my own
property yeah really
I mean well there's four species that
are do that in my book you just need a
chainsaw but I think it literally take
me to jail for doing uh if I cut down
trees that are endangered ate too much
government just the one thing that makes
me once in a while say damn I'm gonna
join the Tea Party Jeremy why is getting
involved in Yemen a danger to American
interests what did you were just there I
was just in Yemen look that the fact is
that there that would you chew the cop I
did chew the cut everyone choose the cop
yes I've read about that so yeah in that
part of the world caught its rights like
its course between pot and the coca leaf
it's it's a stimulant and you chew it
and you get this sort of you know dizzy
gillespie pouch you know in your and
your cheek does it make you high and it
yeah I mean it's a it's a it's an upper
it's a stimulant and the Yemenis call it
building castles in the sky you know you
sit around you chill in a do on you hang
out it's where all the business is done
the whole country stops working at two
o'clock it's completely full of half
done construction projects cuz everyone
goes to buy their cot at about ten
o'clock by you know by noon their figure
out where they're gonna chew the
by two they're choosing thing about this
we've taken our war on drugs to an
extreme the only people in Yemen not
chewing khat are CIA agents because
they're banned from chewing khat so they
can't go to where it's truly US
diplomats cannot chew khat spies US
employees not allowed to chew khat it's
where all all the intelligence would
come from a meeting with people at akkad
chew to make a plan to get permission so
it's being a journalist there any
journalist who's serious is gonna go to
cannot choose why can't they get
something that looks like Cod Britain I
got I brought that oregano you know
pretend but they don't really chewing
them but they you know the the the
question there's a serious one there
there were about 300 al-qaeda operatives
in Yemen in 2006 there's over a thousand
today according to John Brennan our
drone strikes are so-called targeted
killings our backing of a corrupt regime
has sparked blowback and and we are
chasing down people that don't represent
a tiny fraction of the threat that that
huge financial institutions in this
country to to the actual security of
Americans were afraid of underwear
bombers when we have a financial bomb in
this country and we have over killed
that situation and we're gonna pay the
price because we are creating enemies in
killing innocent people they're in
backing corrupt regimes throughout the
Middle East that will have a legitimate
real reason to fight the United States
not a crazy reason that we will have
taken people from their own families and
that's what I saw on the ground in Yemen
people saying we are going to join with
those fighting you because of what
you've done to us that's serious stuff
that's blowback and that's what we're
seeing in Somalia Pakistan Yemen and
beyond I mean and this is this is a you
know mister Sharia law Barack Obama
that's that's presiding over this policy
and I can't wait for the foreign policy
debate
what's Mitt Romney gonna say Israel Iran
Israel era he'll have nothing nothing to
say because Obama does their game better
but in American presidential elections
foreign policy where I yeah no that's
I'm just saying I want to see that
debate I my opponent is I doubt you
actually see that debate right right Dan
you're killing me
all right um I got a GUI by this cot
stuff on the Internet
[Applause]
Time with Bill Maher asked bill has
guessed your questions right after the
show at HBO calm